[Music]
so i just played through the age of
calamity demo
twice actually and i don't really want
to do any more theorizing on the story
or the plot
of the game since we're already so close
to release now and nintendo is just
putting out so much stuff at this point
that i feel more comfortable just
waiting until the game comes out so
rest assured there's not going to be any
spoilers in terms of the plot of the
game
instead let's break down link's moveset
and some of the crazy combos you can do
now for some of you who are familiar
with the warriors games this might all
be
nothing new but for those who are not
and have only played breath of the wild
this might be more interesting you will
be pleased to know that the characters
have an idol animation
so that's nice anyway down to business
movement left control stick to move
around right control stick to control
the camera
same as in breath of the wild you can
walk by tilting the control stick in any
direction and go into a jog by tilting
it all the way
if you hold it all the way long enough
link will eventually start running
you can perform a dodge by pressing b if
the control stick is in the neutral
position you will do a back flip
or you can use the control stick to
dodge in any direction even diagonally
you can do it pretty quickly too which
looks kind of funny to be honest
something that's good to know is that it
takes quite a while for link to
transition from a jog
into a run but if you perform a forward
dodge while moving forward he will start
running much quicker
do take note that you need to hold b
briefly and not tap it too quickly or
else it doesn't work
you can also go straight into a run from
a standstill without the dodge animation
by pressing b
and forward at the same time but unlike
in breath of the wild you don't need to
hold down b
to keep running after link goes into a
sprint you can just let go of b
next is strafing pressing and holding
down zl will allow you to move around at
walking speed while facing the same
direction
this also makes link hold up his shield
so it doubles as a guard
unlike in breath of the wild however
this doesn't function as a lock-on
mechanic
locking onto enemies is still a thing
but it's done by pressing the right
control stick and you don't need to hold
it
just one click and you're locked on and
you can switch targets by pressing the
right control stick again while strafing
you can still
dodge forward back left and right
however you can dodge diagonally like
before
if you press and hold b after a dodge
and tilt the control stick in any
direction it will cancel guard mode
and makes you sprint in any direction
upon landing now on to the good stuff
attacking and combos so there's three
basic attacks
regular strong and a unique action
regular attacks are performed with y
continuously tapping the button will
perform a basic string you start off
with four swings but in my case i
already unlocked the fifth one and it's
safe to assume that these will be
expanded even further in the full game
in breath of the wild once you start
swinging you can change direction
however in age of calamity you can
next is the strong attacks which you
perform by pressing x
you can also press and hold down x to
charge it up and you can even move while
it's charged now a strong attack on its
own
isn't really that interesting or
effective but combining it with regular
attacks is where the real fun begins
you can cancel your regular attack combo
into a strong move
you can do this by simply performing a
regular string with y and then switch to
x at any point
the strong move will be different
depending on the amount of regular
attacks you performed before it so after
one swing
two swings three swings or four
you can switch to a strong attack at any
point in the combo
except after the finisher now here's
where it gets even more fun
most of the strong moves performed mid
combo can be charged as well by holding
the button down
so for example if you perform a regular
attack then a strong one but instead of
just tapping it you hold the button down
once released the move will be expanded
even further
this doesn't work for every strong
attack but it does for all moves that
follow up from your regular string of
attacks
then we have the unique action performed
with zr which in link's case is using
his bow to fire off a flurry of arrows
link's got quite the drawing hand there
you can aim before or during the attack
by tilting the left control stick
interestingly enough this action has
priority over regular attacks and strong
attacks
so even while you're in the middle of
one of your other attacks pressing zr
will cancel it out
in turn the unique action can also be
cancelled out before the attack by
pressing b
or can be interrupted early by dodging
and then we have the special attack
which can only be performed when this
meter is full simply press a when the
meter is full and you're good to go
but we're not done yet there's a couple
of more things to cover
firstly you can perform either a regular
or a strong attack from a run
a dash attack where link thrusts his
sword forwards or a long shield serve
there's also a shorter shield serve but
that one is part of the regular attack
combo after the second swing
both attacks can be expanded with a
regular combo however you can't follow
up with a strong attack while shield
surfing
neither can you charge it like with the
shorter variant
pressing the regular attack button while
shielding will trigger a shield bash
this can be used to parry or reflect
guardian lasers
also note that after the shield bash you
can continue to hit y to perform your
regular sword swings
next we have aerial attacks and
paragliding there's a couple of
different ways to get airborne in this
game
using cryonis certain strong attacks or
by wall jumping
you can wall jump by dodging into a wall
by pressing b
and then immediately press b again
basically a quick double tap
simply running or walking into a wall
won't work you can even backflip into a
wall and it will still do the job
aside from walls you can also use trees
or any other object that is high enough
even the cryoness pillars you created
yourself once you're airborne you can do
a number of different things
activate the paraglider with b perform a
string of regular attacks
a strong attack or activate your bow
some can even be performed in succession
like the paraglider first
then into a regular attack and then
finish off with a strong attack or your
bow
you don't have to use the paraglider by
the way you can also just skip right to
attack
do keep in mind that you cannot
paraglide after an attack
nor can you do any follow-ups after a
strong attack or your unique action
with all this stuff combined you can
perform some pretty long and nifty
combos so
experiment away and of course as stated
before most of these attacks will likely
be expanded further in the later parts
of the game and there might be many more
possibilities with other weapons like
spears or two-handed weapons
but i think this is already a pretty
strong basis
lastly i will briefly touch upon some of
the other controls
pressing and holding down r will bring
up the four different runes which you
then choose with y
x a or b you got stasis to freeze
enemies in front of you
bombs to uh well bomb stuff the
aforementioned cryoness to launch
yourself upwards and magnesius to grab
iron objects to use against your enemies
the effects of the runes differ from
character to character and also from
situation to situation
for example cryonis can also be used to
counter charging enemies
so i'm not going to go further into them
as of right now
pressing and holding l brings up the
item menu these include any special
weapons you picked up like fire rods or
ice rods and food to replenish your
health
and as is with the runes there's also
more situational attacks
such as a weakness finisher which can be
performed after breaking a strong
enemy's defense and probably much more
but those kinda speak for themselves and
usually it comes down to
pressing the right button at the right
time so that pretty much covers it for
now
i hope that this was of some use to you
and if not
at least entertaining enough to watch of
course everything covered here only
applies to the beginning of the game and
will likely get a lot more crazy down
the line
anyway i will see you next time